this is grow Watts Infiniti 1500
portable power station it's basically
like a power bank you would use to
charge your iPhone but on steroids
instead of fully charging your iPhone
once or twice like a regular power bank
this thing will charge it over a hundred
times or charge your iPad 35 times and
that's of course because this power
station has a
1512 watt hour battery capacity which is
over 15 times more than a 16 inch
MacBook Pros battery pack and it even
supports daisy chaining so you can hook
up three of these things together for a
total of
4536 Watt hours as you can see on the
front it's jam-packed with six USB ports
you can charge multiple devices at once
with two of them being PD fast charging
up to 60 watts and the two USB a ports
in the middle support Quick Charge 3.0
with up to 18 watts of fast charging
power to your iPhone but check out my
favorite feature
yes it has a wireless charger right on
the top with up to 15 watts of wireless
charging power to Androids or of course
seven and a half Qi charging for your
iPhones but the awesome thing about this
is that you also get four AC wall
outlets right here on the side including
a 12 volt car adapter right there for
better compatibility giving you a total
of 12 outputs on this thing of course
including the wireless charger on top
but what makes the outlet special is
that they Supply up to 2 000 watts of
power which means you can power big
things like appliances power tools for
contractors working in remote areas
without power even a space heater which
requires a lot of wattage and not only
that but it can actually output a surge
of up to 4 000 Watts Peak for things
that require surge power like for
example in AC unit a blender a table saw
a tea kettle an electric griddle and
things like that so it basically makes
this thing incredibly useful for camping
trips and other things like that but
it's invaluable in the case of a power
outage allowing you to continue to run
things like your refrigerator your lamps
your Wi-Fi router and of course charge
up your cell phones but taking it even
further it can run a CPAP machine for up
to 15 hours which means it could
literally be a life saver not only that
but the most impressive thing is that it
works as a UPS no not the delivery
service UPS stands for uninterruptible
power source so if your power goes out
this power station will automatically
kick on and Supply Power without your
machine or device that's connected to it
shutting down at all now we actually
used UPS machines in our office in the
case of a power outage so that if the
power goes out our computers and our
data server will continue to run without
instantly shutting down which is
extremely important because our data
could get corrupted and we can lose
files if it wasn't for having them
connected to UPS machines so the fact
that this power station doubles as a UPS
is incredible because you can just leave
it at home plugged into the wall and
have your computers and whatever else
plugged into it just in case the power
goes out and then when you actually need
to take it somewhere on the go on some
kind of trip or whatever else it'll be
fully charged up and ready to go now
moving further let's talk about some of
the other features first off it comes
with two convenient handles that make it
very nice to carry around with it being
36 pounds which is actually very compact
if you consider just how much battery
power is packed into this thing
especially since it doesn't come with an
external power brick everything is built
in now on top of that as you can see it
also has a built-in display which
basically tells you the battery life
percentage left the total output power
that you're using to charge your devices
the time remaining if the output power
remains consistent at the current levels
which is very convenient and you also
get the total input power if you're
charging it and as far as the charging
speed this thing is one of the fastest
in the industry two hours to charge from
zero to a hundred percent which is crazy
and if you're short on time and you only
have let's say one hour before you leave
on a trip or something else it'll charge
up from zero to eighty percent within
that hour and the best part of all is
that if you don't have a traditional
wall outlet nearby for charging if let's
say you're on a trip you have have three
unique methods to charge this up first
you can charge it through your actual
vehicle so let's say you forgot to
charge it up at home and you're driving
to go to camp or hike or road trip
whatever else simply plug this adapter
into your car's 12 or 24 volt ports and
Bam it's charging while you drive for
the second method you can literally use
an EV charger to charge this up in 1.8
hours with the optional EV charging
adapter and finally this thing of course
supports solar charging so use this
adapter to plug in one two three or even
four of grow Watts 200 watt solar panels
for up to 800 watts of solar power
charging this thing up to 100 in just
2.5 hours which I didn't even think
would be possible but the Infiniti 1500
has industry leading MPV T solar
efficiency of up to 99 and the reason
it's so efficient in terms of charging
time is because grow watt is known for
having 11 years of renewable energy
leadership as well as their Best in
Class inverters with them actually being
the number one Global supplier of
residential PV inverters which they're
now using to make awesome products like
this portable power station and even
better they have us-based customer
service but with all of that Hardware
stuff out of the way let's actually get
into the software because this thing has
some awesome software features including
Bluetooth and Wi-Fi connectivity so that
you can use their app to control and
monitor it so here I have the my Grow
app where you can see the power station
is online right here and once you click
in you'll see a bunch of info including
the input and output wattage the time
remaining right here including the
percentage battery life on the right and
and even the temperature over on the
left you could even tap these power
buttons right there to turn on and off
the AC and DC Outlets which is really
cool since you could do it from
basically anywhere then going over into
the settings you can adjust a bunch of
things including the charging speed the
output power you can turn off the beep
sound you can change the auto standby
and auto screen off settings and you can
even update the firmware remotely but
getting back to the power station itself
is just so incredibly useful to have
power anywhere you go like camping or
even on a road trip just to have this
thing in your car charging a bunch of
devices at once while your car is
charging it and keeping it topped off
before you get to your destination and
also for blackouts at home using it as a
UPS or even just a battery bank for your
devices lamps Wi-Fi router whatever this
thing is an absolute Game Changer
especially with the ability to power
very power demanding devices so if
you're interested in checking out grow
Watts Infinity 1500 power station I'll
leave a link to it down in the
description and pin comment below and
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video